ça c'est super cool cette façon dieu
comme ça là dessus est vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool
bref des trucs de fou furieux s'est
franchement génial
[Musique]
je vous demande aujourd'hui je vous ai
parlé il ya quelques jours dürfen le
smartphone de gabe kling d'asus
franchement lien hyper puissant bon je
vous invite à aller voir la vidéo pour
vous remettre en tout cas dans tout le
truc dans les jus de lime rock phone et
je voulais vous parler de plein
d'accessoires que j'ai reçus y met et
franchement c'est complètement officines
parce que il ya un éventail qui est
énorme au niveau des accessoires au
niveau de ce qu'on peut faire
alors je suis pas sûr vous allez tous
les acheter en main que vous soyez
collectionneurs et que vous allez
franchement les moyens je vous explique
et après j'aurais le prix en tout cas ce
qui est possible de faire avec ce
smartphone de gaming c'est génial parce
que les smartphones de gaming sont
arrivés je dirais que le réseau fon fin
2007 2017
je me trompe pas trop là on voit que il
n'ya pas notre marque et son arrivée il
ya xiaomi avec le black shark qui a
resort qui a sorti son réseau fon 2 il
n'y a pas longtemps je voulais également
présente et puis il ya effectivement
asus qui est aussi une marque forte au
niveau du gaming qui voulait pas louper
le coche et qui a sorti son rock funky
hyper bien réussi le smartphone est
génial je vous en prie ne faites plus à
la vidéo qui a déjà été sorti là dessus
mais ils ont sorti a dit qu'au système
hyper complet je pense qu'il va
continuer à se développer et à
s'améliorer dans les années à venir avec
plein d'accessoires c'est franchement
génial vous pour transformer votre
iphone en une manette de jeu c'est juste
hyper cool à claude de petit contrôleur
vous avez un dock qui vous explique un
commissaire s'est franchement top
vous avez un deuxième doc vous expliquer
un lieu aussi à quoi ils servent
d'ailleurs c'est hyper hyper cool
vous avez un twin view doc qui vous
transforme votre iphone en espèces de
nintendo 3ds enfin il ya plein
d'accessoires
ils sont franchement toc aussi bien les
uns que les autres
il y en a alors on va vraiment un sens
et je pense que ça vaut le coup d'aller
dessus elle a d'autres je suis un peu
moins sur veut plus dubitatif enfin il
ya des choses qui sont vraiment
intéressants et je viens tout de suite
est en deuil vous allez voir vous allez
pas être au bout de vos surprises pour
le rock faune on a déjà vu on va passer
très rapidement sur le premier
accessoire que je trouve vraiment super
cool c'est ça
twin view doc alors le twin view doc
c'est une espèce de
nintendo 3ds on va transformer en gros
votre emploi dont nintendo 3ds vous avez
votre boîte vous l'ouvrez comme ça vous
prenez votre smartphone vous enlevez
cyril partie caoutchouc quat'sous et
vous venez l insérer directement dedans
il vient de trouver sa place à
l'intérieur on baisse ça marche c'est
comme ça et ensuite vous avez juste un
petit locke a poussé la salle ferme
il a plus lever et là votre smartphone
se transforme directement hop on enlève
tout ça avec un double écran et ça c'est
vraiment génial vous avez réussi votre
petit bouton de volume que vous allez
retrouver pour mettre le son est poussée
à fond si vous voulez jouer de cette
manière là on va se faire une petite
course de voiture un petit aspect neuf
et franchement c'est vraiment hyper
bluffant de jouer comme ça c'est hyper
cool en bas vous y retrouver la partie
un peu commandes aller il ya du tchador
j'adore vraiment voulu régler vraiment
comme vous voulez vous pouvez le mettre
comme ça si vous êtes un peu plus sur le
fût pouvait le mettre comme ça tac je
choisis la voiture je joue et derrière
j'ai aussi de petites gâchette là vous
voyez qui me servent à jouer ça c'est
super cool cette façon de jouer comme ça
là dessus est vraiment vraiment vraiment
cool
bref des trucs de fou furieux s'est
franchement génial ça transforme
complètement votre votre rock phone en
espèce de petite console portative
trouve ça vraiment génial en bas vous
avez exactement le même design que en
eau au niveau du roc phone c'est
vraiment bien les petites mises à jour à
faire ça va vite c'est cool ça vous fait
une batterie de 6000 milles et en perd
heures le truc qui franchement coujoux
10 à les contrôleurs vous avez un bouton
ici pour venir l'allumé pour l'éteindre
vous pouvez la naviguer directement dans
vos applis enfin c'est vraiment cool et
ce qui est cool en plus ça tu sais que
vous pouvez ensuite à l'estrie mail si
vous les strings et surtout vous pouvez
le faire enfin là il ya pas mal de
possibilités
je trouve ça c'est vraiment intéressant
c'est un premier accessoire qui est
hyper cool et ça pour moi en tout cas
dans tous les accessoires qu'on va voir
chez asus sort du rock phone pour moi je
suis là c'est vraiment un coup de coeur
ensuite on arrive sur le mobile destock
doc c'est dur à dire des stops des hawks
bref alors ça c'est bien mais c'est pas
fait pour moi pourquoi je vous explique
en fait c'est un c'est un dock qui vous
sert pour brancher votre votre
désolé pouvait lire ne pas casser
tu me fait des frayeurs quand c'est
comme ça donc là vous brancher
directement votre rock phone ici sur le
dessus et l'intérêt c'est que ça va
transformer complètement votre rock
phone en lités centrale et vous allez
pouvoir rajouter des choses dessus
l'intérêt si vous avez plein de port à
l'aéroport micro force pdif le jack et
là vous avez votre hdmi fin vous avez
pas mal de port vous à les brancher
dessus un clavier vous à les brancher
dessus une souris vous à les brancher
dessus un écran vous à les brancher
dessus une prise ethernet si vous voulez
pas passer par la case z pour voulais
pas te bouffer ou leur passé par louis
xi gouv fr et l'idée c'est que pour des
parties de jeux en réseau sur un grand
écran clavier souris vous allez pouvoir
le faire tourner alors malheureusement
n'étant pas moi même un gamer n'ayant
pas clavier et souris qui fonctionne
avec un macbook pro dont zac soir là je
les ai pas par contre un truc qui est
plutôt cool
si vous êtes gamer et vous voulez
continuer à garder votre smartphone pour
jouer dessus à vos parts qui voulait pas
vous en mettez ça peut être cool heures
après ça va pas se substituer à un
ordinateur de gaming je dirais c'est
plus pour pousser l'expérience des ming
de votre smartphone sur une expérience
pc
l'idée à mon avis c'est plus ça pouvoir
profiter de forte taille pouvoir
profiter d'un pib j'ai directement
clavier souris ne pensez pas que vous
allez avoir la même expérience de jeu
que sur un pc de gaming
ça sera strictement pas le cas par
contre ça pour ajouter une autre façon
de jouer et ça peut être intéressant que
ça peut éviter surtout que vous jouiez
tout le temps sur un petit écran vous
rentrez chez vous avez un écran plus
grand et plus de confort il ya plus de
possibilités clavier souris c'est cool
donc ça c'est un point que trouve aussi
assez intéressant puisqu'on est dans les
docks restons si vous avez le
professional doc d'asus
alors ça c'est l'accessoire qui
m'appellent le moins je le trouvais
intéressant mais disons que vous pouvez
trouver sensiblement la même chose à la
concurrence donc donc c'est peut-être
bien qu'asus l'ennemi dans l'écosystème
du rock phone mais c'est pas le truc le
plus essentiel qui va vous faire un
effet whaou avec votre smartphone en
gros vous avez un petit job c'est un
tube que vous allez connecté en usb type
c vous avez ici la connectique avec ses
pareils de l'usb type celle usb type a
dû âge
emi pour brancher un moniteur vous avez
de l'internet enfin voyez c'est un petit
hub qui peut vous servir aussi bien pour
un pc pour brancher sur de l'usb type c
mais bon sur un roc phone c'est pas
l'accessoire qui me paraît en tout cas
le plus indispensable puisque dans les
accessoires j'en profiterai aussi une
petite coque pour votre rock funky et là
qui est sympa qui est belle qui va bien
que leur est bon maintenant je vous
passez à un direct ce soir avec nouvelle
the fuck que je trouve vraiment hyper
intéressant c'est ça c'est le game
vaïsse pour votre au rock folk
je trouve ça franchement hyper cool
parce que ça transforme vraiment votre
iphone en console de jeux bon par contre
ce qui me fait un peu peur c'est le côté
un peu plastique avec son milieu j'ai
toujours peur en termes de robustesse et
de solidité
par contre l'expérience est assez sympa
et ça je vais vous expliquer ça
fonctionne de concert avec un autre
accessoire qui est juste là qui est le
oui jig display doc c'est super cool
vous prenez votre iphone vous le
branchez une partie là l'autre partie là
c'est un peu lastic vous tirer ça vient
ça se positionne comme ça sur le
principe je trouve ça franchement cool
par contre avec un côté humain j'ai
l'impression que c'est fragile alors je
ne pense pas qu'il soit fragile et que
ça risque de se casser mais c'est vrai
que ça bouge un peu ce qui est
franchement cool avec poggi voyez c'est
que là vous allez pouvoir par exemple
sur pib j'ai complètement ma paie donc
là je vais jouer avec les petit joystick
j'avance du recul hop je me déplace je
vais pouvoir mettre des coups de poing
faire ce que je veux je peux m jaloux
directement à mes touches les fonctions
je veux fait un vrai mapping donc ça
c'est cool ça me permet vraiment d'aller
plus loin en terme d'expérience de jeu
up
alors il ya un petit coup à prendre mais
c'est franchement bien et ça me permet
de jouer avec une vraie manette physique
directement là sur mon smartphone donc
ça c'est franchement hyper hyper hyper
hyper hyper plus tard appréciable
vous êtes non pas bien
mince j'ai pu en mettre
je suis en train de me faire
complètement éclatée et en plus de ça ce
qui est bien c'est que vous téléchargez
l'application google voice live et vous
avez accès à tout un catalogue de jeux
complètement compatible avec ce
contrôleur là vous avez plein de jeux
qui sont complètement compatible donc ça
c'est leur favori vous avez vous
choisissez les gratuits les payant ce
que vous voulez comme type de jeu enfin
c'est franchement hyper cool
donc ça c'est bien pour de la mobilité
maintenant si vous voulez jouer à la
maison avec ça vous pouvez aller
beaucoup plus loin par contre il vous
faut c'est accessoire là c'est le wigig
display doc d'asus vous avez une
connexion sans fil et vous allez pouvoir
jouer directement avec votre iphone sur
votre télé alors le point intéressant
c'est que lorsque vous jouez à plusieurs
vous allez pouvoir montrer à tous vos
amis votre famille à quel point vous
êtes fort en transposant dans votre jeu
directement travaux télé c'est
franchement hyper cool que vous avez
votre petit dock qui est là qui raccordé
en hdmi alors je le débranche pour vous
montrez vous avez une prise hdmi vous
avez une prise usb type aa vous avez
votre commande alimentation un bouton
pour l'allumer pour éteindre et lui il
va se connecter directement son fils à
votre robe phone j'allume mon iphone je
viens je le connecte directement ici là
avec la fonction willocq hop ça ne
connecte directement et je vais pouvoir
transposer directement le contenu de mon
smartphone directement sur ma télé donc
la voyez c'est super cool tu peux
vraiment complètement en profiter jouer
directement et devoirs alors voir soit
sur mon roc phone soit sur mon grand
écran et franchement c'est hyper hyper
hyper hyper appréciable donc au final ça
fait plein d'accessoires pour iphone
plein d'accessoires qui sont franchement
cool franchement sympa alors je vous dis
moi les deux vraiment que je trouve
vraiment cool c'est le game weiss qui
vous permet de jouer sur votre télé avec
le hub donc ça c'est vraiment rigolo
mais celui que je préfère par dessus
tous c'est le trine view doc qui ont
fait un peu comme nintendo 3ds avec la
puissance du rock phone avec l'audio du
rock phone je trouve ça franchement bien
et d'une manière générale je trouve ça
vraiment un excellent boulot avec un
écosystème très complet et c'est
vraiment cool
si vous donnez les prix parce que vous
allez voir c'est bien par contre le gros
frein c'est très cher
le roc fois non lui-même vous touchez un
peu moins de 900 euros
déjà ça fait un petit budget par le
smartphone il est vraiment très sympa
ensuite lorsqu'on veut trouver un peu
plus de matos bon je passe tout de suite
par la petite coque coûte 39 99 c'est
pas très cher oncle a jusque-là s'avance
les pas trop trop mal on va aller sur le
twin view doc celui que je préfère qui
vous transforme en espèces de nintendo
3ds
alors j'ai pris la montée ce très bon
petit papier le twin view dr men 329
euros 99 cole twin view doc
ça veut dire que vous voulez votre swing
du dock et vous voulez le rock fun avec
vous êtes à peu près 1200 euros 1229
lesquels ça fait tout de suite hyper
cher c'est un peu le frein ensuite vous
avez le gate weiss le game base qui est
mon avis le deuxième accessoires qui est
vraiment sympa qui coûte un peu moins de
100 euros 99 euros 1,99 et si vous
voulez pousser l'expérience le plus loin
possible et l'envoyer directement sur
votre télé c'est deux accessoires
fonctionnent ensemble celui là coûte 269
euros 99 ça veut dire que là on est à
360 euros ensuite
le catastrophe monsieur vous aimez le
petit dock qui coûte un peu moins de 80
euros qui est pas hyper cher
ensuite on va avoir celui là le mobileye
des stops boc qui coûte un peu moins de
200 euros 199 euros 99
je trouve qu'elle a vu ça fait vraiment
un excellent boulot avec un écosystème
qui est hyper complet autour du rock
phone maintenant le problème c'est que
c'est très premium peut-être trop
premium beaucoup trop cher mais ça va
être un frein pour beaucoup de personnes
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir se l'offrir avec
quelques accessoires tout de suite ils
ont les moyens c'est un vrai frein sur
ça dommage parce que je trouve que ça va
vraiment dans le bon sens est vraiment
hyper hyper intéressant mais par contre
avec leurs consommateurs en face ça fait
dépenser beaucoup d'argent s'il ya deux
trois accessoires qui vous plaisent vous
à plus de 1500 euros
après tout c'est un vrai frein je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez mark et moi
tout ça directement en bas en
commentaire pourquoi ce papier je trouve
que on va vraiment dans le bon sens
c'est ça qui est vraiment intéressant on
a un smartphone qui permet de jouer à 62
gaming tout l'extra derrière un
écosystème complet et je trouve ça
vraiment cool et je vous invite
également à vous abonner avait consulté
ma playlist pour l'être à les différents
smartphones il ya des smartphones de
gamme il n'y a pas que des smartphones
de gaming et aussi des objets tels que
le tarif il ya plein de trucs donc vous
invite
abonné à rester connectés premier
souhaite vous soyez ça je vous embrasse
et à très bientôt
ciao